uh
time is running out
the prophecies say final winter leads to
ragnarok
war is coming
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there finding out who i
am who loki is
i will not allow you to pick a fight
with god
i don't want to fight anyone
i just want answers
and if those answers lead to war with
asgard
maybe that's what mother wants
we do not know what mother watching
well
i recognize that dull expression
anywhere
odin's got tricks up his sleeve we
haven't dared to consider
what if there was someone who could help
us
you mean here
the old god of war in these lands who is
dead
well for a dead man who didn't seem
pretty keen on seeing he wasn't found
if he's out there
we gotta find him
come in
what all yarns need to happen
we're trying to stop ragnarok to help
people
and what if the only way to do that is
war
war is not the only way
stop thinking like a father for a moment
and start thinking like a general
you seem like a calm and reasonable
person
are you a calm and reasonable person
[Music]
in moments of crisis
panic does nothing
harness it
[Music]
let it serve you
here
are you coming with us
[Applause]
[Music]
you'll get your answer soon enough
well some of them
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it happened an age ago
but when i recall i see it true
on a night of wintry fog
the rule of death was stolen
and the demigods began to fall
starting with godwin the golden
queen america was driven to the brink
the shattering ensued a wall that
wrought only darkness
the elder ring was broken
but by whom
and why
what could the demigods ever hope to win
by boring
[Music]
[Music]
the conqueror of the stars
general time
and the blade of nickel and melania vii
these two were the mightiest
[Music]
but there would be no victor
[Music]
and so we inhabit a fractured world
awaiting the arrival of the eldenborn
[Music]
unless of course
thou should take the crown
[Music]
constellation starship frontier we have
you on scanners
[Music]
we are still going
they say
the wonder is
not that the field of stars is so vast
but that we have measured it
you're part of constellation now
part of our
family
what you found
it's the key to unlocking
everything
[Music]
we reach
this is all we've been working towards
we've come to the beginning of
humanity's final journey
[Music]
[Music]
to discover what's out there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it
so
so
essentials
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
wake up son
oh
oh
hq
[Music]
i
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
bad boys
[Music]
it seems i'm unfashionably late
but i'm ready to give you everything you
want
[Music]
break
[Music]
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we got
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
over here
so
it's too dangerous
[Music]
all of you are the worst of the worst of
the worst
still
you're good at what you do
even if what you do is far from good
welcome to task force x
let me take a look at you
a muscle head
a nut job
something that offends my eyes
and a homeless person
you're perfect
just checking we're all seeing that
thing right this has one way ticket
written all over it
what what the hell have you sent us
youtube it's a bloody war zone out here
eyes up people congratulations
you're the first asset to make it into
metropolis alive
[Music]
i was just about to do that
[Music]
task force x
your new mission
is to kill the justice league
[Music]
[Music]
raise your hand if taking on the justice
league is the worst idea you've ever
heard
i can't design that
[Music]
what did you think would happen you'd
crawl out of your cells swoop in save
the day which super heroes did you say
you were undead
he's not gonna make it
[Music]
the penguin is in flight repeat the
penguin is in flight
then let's flip his wings
oh my god he's gotten up hitting him
again
he's ran out the door
somebody stop him
did that get him
no
oh it it very much did not get him a
waller
waller blow up his head
my daughter
a new threat comes to our shores
and i must call you home
restore what has been broken
unite old enemies
forge new ones
you are a hero
but you can be more
you can be
a leader
you
are wonder woman
[Music]
batman
jim gordon
they thought they had a handle on this
city
they never did
you
[Music]
don't stand a chance
because they're always watching
always listening
pulling everybody's strings
mine
yours
[Applause]
but no one talks about them
[Applause]
not a whispered word is said the court
of owls is a myth
they're listening
[Music]
uh
so
so
so
if you really want to go down this
rabbit hole you need to know there's no
coming back from it
trump
for as long as i can remember i have
looked for an equal
one who could push me
one who could surprise me
one who could even beat me
yet all i found
is disappointment
will one of you
finally give me what i desire
yes
we
will
[Music]
playstation
and she said
with our swords
we will forge new stories
to strike the gods that haunt us
you
might see me as weak
but i will show you what lies behind my
eyes
[Music]
we will embrace our suffering
soothe our scars of grief
and break their siege of our minds
you may see them as gods
but we will show you
what lies behind their eyes
to risk your own life
for what you believe is your sacrifice
to make
to lead others to death
brings a different kind of burden
one that senua
would have to learn
look at the bones that's going to be you
that's going to be
no one's ever killed a giant
[Music]
those whose eyes are clouded by fear are
besieged by the ghosts that haunt them
senua saw that to win the war we must
break this siege
break it
with an unshakable truth
break it
with an impossible feat
get ready
yes
yes
[Music]
the barracks
[Applause]
over here
[Music]
shut him down
um
it's me it wants to kill
ready
get ready
attack
[Applause]
he's seen you
[Music]
i know you he needs you
[Music]
peggy 18.
we all come to a story with hopes and
expectations
looking for an answer
sometimes it would be better to live
with that hope
without ever finding the story
this is not the story you want it to be
this story
will eat you alive
this story
is a monster
and monsters wear many faces
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is swan producer
at blue12 studio and today i'm going to
show you more about stray
[Music]
[Music]
in stray you play as a cat who has
fallen inside the mysterious and
forgotten city separated from his family
and injured he will have to explore and
survive in this unwelcoming environment
[Music]
from the cat's unique point of view
players must navigate their way through
the dangers of this unfriendly place and
use the cat's skills to solve puzzles
and uncover mysteries along the way
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
along his journey the cat will meet a
small drone named b12
[Music]
using the drone's ability to interact
with objects in the world and
communicate with the strange inhabitants
of this secluded place together they
will work to learn more about the
secrets of this forgotten community of
human-like machines
[Music]
what
[Music]
of course the cat will always be a cat
and his adventures will be filled with
friendly and playful interactions with
his new world
[Music]
but these machines are not the only
inhabitants of the city and some
encounters will not be as friendly
[Music]
[Music]
running fast jumping and using stairs to
avoid dangers will all be vital if you
want to escape this city and be reunited
with family
[Music]
[Music]
unless you find a way to defend yourself
and the prey might become the hunter
[Music]
stray is coming to ps4 ps5 as well as pc
in early 2022 and we can't wait to show
you more
[Music]
[Music]
teenage mutant ninja turtles teenage
mutant ninja turtles teenage mutant
ninja turtles
[Music]
these turtle boys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
big
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a tale from a long long time ago
when the sinnoh region was still only a
vast wilderness
[Music]
a certain village bustled with the
comings and goings of people
while in the mountains and seas pokemon
roamed as they pleased
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ever since the day the portal network
collapsed stranding us in these realms
we have searched for a way home
lost
and alone in the dangerous labyrinth of
fantastical worlds
welcome to the lands of faye
[Music]
every portal is a chance for salvation
uniting the lost survivors
or leading us deeper
into this nightmare
nightingale
our beacon of hope
but beyond our reach
as long as we stand together
our journey will unite us
you
the realm walkers
are all that is left
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
done
trapped
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
visiting and we hope you enjoyed the
show freddy and the gang are pretty
tired but they'll be back again next
week after a few days of scheduled
maintenance
freddy fazbear's mega pizza plexus now
closed initiating nighttime protocols no
no wait i'm still here
i want you
[Music]
you should be able to escape when the
security doors reopen at six am
until then keep moving and try not to
draw attention to yourself if there is
another way out i will help you find it
i promise
[Music]
so
[Music]
please make your way to the front of the
building where you will be given novelty
glasses a voucher for one free soda
refill and where you will sign a legal
disclaimer releasing us of all liability
for anything that might have happened
during your visit
have an awesome night and we'll see you
again soon
you like to take a short survey about
your experience
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cause i'm a superstar
is
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
yes
[Music]
show me your everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
talking
[Music]
so
[Music]
haha
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
with this
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
beautiful and mysterious sci-fi world
this is just one part of the zetta halo
ring the largest most wide-open
environment we've ever built and we
can't wait for you to explore it
[Music]
[Music]
the heart of halo is spartan 117 the
master chief
in the next chapter of the chief's story
he'll face his greatest challenge yet
but
they're not alone in the fight
the main batteries are shut down
we're stuck out here
[Music]
[Music]
i told you
it's enough
so i see
[Music]
i need you to understand
there's not much
[Music]
[Music]
what happened
where is cortana
the rogue ai known as cortana is gone
she's been deleted
how
by you
of course not
did you hit your head or something
don't you remember my instructions were
to enter this installation imitate
cortana and lock her down for retrieval
yours were to take her back to the
infinity for deletion
so if it wasn't you
okay then
there's something else
on successful deployment my deletion
routine was supposed to complete
still here
good
good
something stopped your deletion
we need to find out why
but
this wasn't the mission the missions
changed
they always do
are you sure
[Music]
peggy 16.
entry team you're glad to proceed
off
now
please help me
[Music]
foreign
door ram is ready sir copy that entry
team go when ready
drop the gun
okay it's been 11 years
and we all want to know
what's up with skate
[Music]
the truth is it's early we're still
working on it you're joking has anyone
seen gameplay
well a couple people have seen it what
people
sick about the time they've seen it
it just looks beautiful this whole open
world
escapes you oh cool you're listening to
the fans
and those the board pops and the
throwdown yeah no come first
yeah you can climb
playing with all the homies will be so
sick explain that spinning rail can you
do that to anything like i don't want to
look like anybody else you guys are in
the future
wait the game is the game's what wow
that's interesting really our big thing
is don't stop
you're not gonna show us anything dude
why are you asking me
so we're just so we're just gonna end
here
that's that's it
ah this is such a tease
[Music]
the zero point isn't floating we've lost
control save yourself if i don't stop
this it could destroy all existence you
have your orders now get out of there
i'm gonna do what we should have done
from the very start i'm going to the
seventh you took an oath
[Music]
i'm gonna need that
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
healing
[Music]
[Music]
come on come on
[Music]
unbelievable
it actually worked
look
i know you have no reason to trust me
but
oh no
i can get you to jenno
and the sisters
i can get you all of them
but i need your help to fix that
you have a deal
for now
oh that's very reassuring
time to get to work
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings we await the light at the end
in life and in death glory to mother
miranda
[Music]
but you're whining we're almost there
rose
where are you
hello
if there are any survivors out there
come to my
to louise's house near the fields
[Music]
oh no
they're coming
who is
what the hell was that
stop
shouting you'll draw the monsters
tell me what is going on around here it
doesn't make any sense
mother miranda has always protected us
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
[Music]
let's see how special you are
is this all that's left from your entire
village all that's left
there is no one left
we can bust out with this
lichens
and gentlemen
we thank you for waiting and now that
the games begin
there is no safe every sorry fast out
there has been ripped and hacked
tomorrow we'll all be dead
ethan
ethan
winters
welcome
get off of me
stay the [ __ ] down
i gotta say i'm surprised you made it
this far
it'd be a shame if something happened to
you now
you killed mia now do me and finish the
job
hey everyone
we've been quiet for some time since
like the rest of the world we had some
unforeseen hurdles to clear
but the wait is over
let's dive into the open world of dying
light ii
[Music]
the last slice of dying light 2
showcased a mission from the main
storyline you get after those [ __ ]
you saw how your decisions influenced
the narrative and notably changed the
environment
this time we want to give you a broader
look at the game and a sneak peek at
some of the things we'll be talking
about in upcoming months
in dying light 2 you become aidan
caldwell an outsider trying to unravel a
tangled mystery from his past
its trail leads him to the city
probably the last bastion of mankind in
the world
[ __ ]
at first you feel like this intense
brutal place will tear you apart but
then you meet the night runners veteran
survivors who help people in better days
by the way i'm a haircut you were a
night runner you used to help people
remember my runners are gone finished
a myth
and although it's not entirely clear you
can trust them
you need allies in the dark
and these are the modern dark ages it's
been 15 years since the apocalypse and
the world has changed
the old civilization has fallen
but a new one has been built on its
ashes
people fight desperately for scarce
resources
rules are broken and weakness is
punished
she's innocent
three factions struggle for position in
the city
survivors pride themselves on being able
to adapt to any circumstances and cobble
together safe zones almost everywhere
peacekeepers loyal soldiers who want to
impose their version of law and order
and trample all in their path
renegades ex-prisoners serving their
ruthless colonel seeking to become sole
rulers of the city where
is
use these factions to reach your goal
help or harm them to reshape the city to
your liking
just remember each faction contains
complex characters
nosey parker ain't you
got some kind of bad habit of yours
so will you follow cold calculation
or your heart the bizarre needs good
people
help us and you'll find a home here
some in the city offer no chance for an
alliance bandits outlaws and common
thugs live only to plunder and kill
plunging the streets into chaos
yet nightfall scares all of them equally
darkness changes the rules of the world
as the light fails monsters crawl out of
hiding to prey on the poor souls caught
outside the safety of uv rays
hordes of infected pour into the streets
like decaying lava
the deadly spawn of 15 years of mutation
and evolution
your only escape exploit the city's
verticality and flee to the
though roofs there you are never safe
from swift and deadly virals
yet night brings opportunity as well
nests rife with infected during the day
now light empty
[Applause]
to explore them you must tread carefully
but those brave enough to face the
terrors of the night can loot a jackpot
[Music]
luckily you have all the tools you need
to survive
your extraordinary parkour skills allow
you to navigate even the most
treacherous terrain
[Music]
[Applause]
on the roofs you can count on your
parkour acrobatics to save your life
but often you'll have to face your
enemies head on and then you have to be
smart
resourceful
and determined
[Music]
we've worked hard on the essence of our
combat making sure swinging a big meaty
weapon is fun satisfying and well
executed
but even the most brutal fights can be
tactical as well
you have multiple ways to hone your
skills toward the gameplay style that
suits you best
it's up to you if you focus mostly on
mobility and parkour
or aggressive blunt force combat
or a crafty approach where the tools
you've created get the job done every
ability you learn can be a game changer
and possibly a new favorite move
things move fast and quick in dying
light too each moment matters each move
could mean triumph or defeat
choose your actions and friends
carefully
everything you do in the city can
reshape the gameplay environment change
the course of the narrative and decide
the fate of the city's residents
but most importantly you decide your own
fate as well you're about to turn
make sure
to stay human
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
up
time to go to work
[Music]
let's get started
hold on
you're alive but not safe
let's begin please
ready
hello my name is dan salvato
i'm the creator of the psychological
horror game doki doki literature club
and now after a lot of really passionate
work from a whole bunch of people i'm
delighted to share doki doki literature
club plus with you for the first time
i'm sure some of you already can't wait
to revisit your friends in the club but
if you're new to doki doki literature
club we're excited for you to meet the
club members for the first time on pc
nintendo switch playstation or xbox this
summer
ddlc plus gives the original pc game
high definition visuals and brings it to
a number of new platforms it's also
packed with all kinds of new features
and content for both existing fans and
new players to experience and enjoy
there's a lot of cool stuff for me to go
over but there are also some things that
you'll have to discover for yourself
when you play the game ddlc is a game
that explores the unique kind of
relationship that people can have with
fictional characters and the
relationship they have with video games
in general i wanted to make a game that
causes people to think more deeply about
how they mentally and emotionally
process their experience with fiction
and using psychological horror to deeply
disturb them is a really effective way
of achieving that
i always felt like the members of the
literature club deserved more of a space
to get to know each other and kind of
explore their interpersonal
relationships
so for ddlc plus i wrote a new storyline
that i call the side stories the side
stories are unrelated to the events of
the original game and they instead focus
on how all the club members went from
first meeting each other to becoming
close friends
i really wanted to create an environment
where these characters have to
learn to overcome their communication
barriers and
respect each other's needs and reflect
on themselves and i think that will be
really meaningful to those of you who
relate to the characters or maybe even
find yourselves in similar situations i
think this is a great time for some
wholesome storytelling that can help
keep us inspired to continue improving
ourselves and our relationships with
others
the side stories also have a brand new
soundtrack to go along with them
music has always been an important part
of ddlc
and really important to me personally as
a part of playing video games i love how
music tracks sort of absorb all the
emotions you feel during the game and
how it all comes rushing back whenever
you hear the songs again so for the side
stories i brought in a new composer
nikki kylar who shares the same passion
and understanding of the special impact
of video game music nikki and i worked
really closely together on songs that
have some familiar catchy melodies along
with a bunch of brand new ones
to make it even better ddlc plus has a
built-in music player the music player
has 26 music tracks in total i really
hope you enjoy discovering the new music
as you play the side stories which will
also unlock them in the music player
speaking of unlockables another fun new
feature is the picture gallery where you
can unlock pictures as you play the game
there are more than 100 unlockable
pictures like game artwork wallpapers
and never before seen concept sketches
of certain memorable scenes from the
game i think it's a fun way to encourage
people to try new things in ddlc and see
if they can discover all the content
it's not easy to reach 100 content
completion but i bet if you and your
friends share each of your own
discoveries you'd be able to do it
together
that's about it for the stuff i'm ready
to talk about today
for everything else you'll just have to
discover it yourself
i know that there's always a concern
with re-releases or special editions
having a whole bunch of changes to them
or the original content being tampered
with in some way so we thoughtfully
included all the new content in a way
that ensures the main game doki doki
literature club is as authentic and true
to the original as possible
overall i really wanted to make ddlc
plus
not only really special for existing
fans but also a fantastic and accessible
way for new players to get in on the
psychological horror experience
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i am so proud of you
[Music]
do you know what a birthright is peter
[Music]
something that's a part of you
like your name
gardeners of the galaxy
what no rocket so i let groot fill out
the paperwork
so we got fine we appear to be
6963 units short i know we clearly
need a plan
if you see anything with gloves by the
tracks let me know we got this
no
we're all professionals here right maybe
we can work something out
you had one job quill i did exactly what
the more no killing teammates that's who
it's literally in your contract i made
no such commitment
in less than three cycles all would be
lost the galaxy cannot be saved either
quickly we can do this together
[Music]
oh
no no of course i will i'll call you
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
i got a little job for you pal
they mess with me they measure the
biggest boy in town
i'm glad to see things back the way they
used to be
[Music]
oh that ought to put the coyote in
chicken coop huh
[Music]
and if he's ratting us out
kill him
it's easy haven't you ever seen a movie
you saying like it's a bad thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]